("Iron", Woodkid)
(cris de foule)
-Tous les ans, les mêmes visages
déchirés par l'effort.
Les mêmes foules
agglutinées sur le bord des routes.
Le Tour
de France, c'est un village
de 4500 personnes,
2400 véhicules
et 35 km de câbles.
Une transhumance
qui balaye la France
durant trois semaines, en juillet,
depuis plus de 100 ans.
Derrière la petite reine
et l'exploit sportif,
une superproduction
qui met en selle
des centaines d'entreprises, de
médias, de sponsors
et de collectivités locales.
Chaque année, des centaines
de communes candidatent
pour accueillir le Tour,
malgré des tickets d'entrée
toujours plus élevés
et des cahiers
des charges très complexes.
Quelles sont les retombées
pour les collectivités ? Comment
se prépare cet événement sportif
sur les routes ?
Pour sa 100e édition,
plongez dans les coulisses du Tour.
---
Il est 5h, ce 3 juillet 2013.
Le ronflement des moteurs
réveille l'hippodrome Borély
à Marseille.
-A priori, on joue comme ça.
(anglais)
Tu commences ici.
(musique douce)
C'est la ligne d'arrivée, pour toi.
-Comme tous les matins,
le ballet des équipes
du Tour de France
est déjà en scène
pour cette cinquième étape.
La rade s'éveille
et le chef d'orchestre,
c'est Jean-Louis Pagès.
Sous ses ordres :
deux cents personnes,
plusieurs nationalités.
(musique jazz)
(anglais)
-Comme ça, oui.
-Les caméras ?
-D'accord.
C'est parfait. Merci.
Vous pouvez installer
le camion sur le côté ?
-Pas de problème.
-Bonne journée.
-Sa passion, ce n'est pas le vélo,
mais l'organisation.
-On enlèvera les plots
pour installer les tribunes.
Mais c'était prévu.
Si l'engin est là,
c'est que c'était prévu.
C'est pas...
Et c'est pas compliqué.
Le monsieur veut absolument
que ce soit compliqué.
C'est pas compliqué.
C'est du vélo, c'est un Meccano,
on joue avec des voitures
et des camions.
Et en plus, les gens sont gentils.
Ils sont plus costauds que moi,
mais bon...
(allemand)
Guten Morgen !
-Dans moins de 12h, les coureurs
passeront la ligne d'arrivée.
Tribunes, salle de presse,
cars-régie,
tout doit être monté avant midi.
Pour les équipes de la ville
et du Tour,
c'est un peu
leur contre-la-montre.
("Thé à la menthe", La Caution)
---
-Après vous avoir dit : "Bonjour
et bienvenue à Marseille"...
-BONJOUR, JEAN-LOUIS...
(Jean-Louis Pagès rit)
-On n'est pas en retard...
Les gars, on se fout tous
la pression,
la course n'arrive qu'à 5h !
Pardon, 17h !
On a le temps, on a le temps...
..pour que vous...
---
..pour que vous puissiez aller
dor-mir !
-Cette année, à 57 ans,
c'est son 30e Tour de France.
Alors il connaît sa mécanique
et il sait qu'il doit
dorloter ses équipes.
-C'est un travail d'orfèvre
que nous faisons, même si ce matin,
ça a pu vous choquer,
dans l'enlèvement des plots.
C'était prévu !
Pas de question ?
Pas de souci ?
Bonne journée !
On sait la volonté des élus,
simplement, ce que les élus
ne connaissent pas,
en tout cas, les représentants
de collectivités, etc.,
c'est ça, c'est ce bazar,
là derrière.
On a besoin, sur une arrivée
d'étape, de 7 ha de surface.
Ici, à Marseille, hippodrome
Borély, on est tout à fait dedans.
Sur un départ d'étape,
c'est entre 3 et 4 ha,
donc, là aussi, il faut le volume
pour le village du Tour,
et il faut des structures d'accueil
pour une salle de presse
et différents éléments.
Nous le savons. A nous de marier
ces contraintes techniques
avec la volonté des élus,
donc, trouver le bon compromis.
Tout est conforme,
pas de souci,
simplement, il faut
qu'on comprenne que le Tour,
c'est le tour de France, en fait,
et qu'il a cette particularité,
et c'est normal,
d'être itinérant.
Ca peut paraître le bazar,
on peut dire ce qu'on veut,
mais c'est un bazar organisé.
-Cette ligne d'arrivée,
c'est l'aboutissement de huit mois
de travail avec les collectivités.
Après la présentation du Tour,
fin octobre,
Jean-Louis part
à la rencontre des élus.
Bilan : plus de 80 réunions,
120 000 km, 200 nuits à l'hôtel.
Pour l'ancien prof d'histoire-géo,
beaucoup de pédagogie.
-Je pense que mon boulot,
c'est qu'avec les élus,
quand l'arrivée a lieu,
on se regarde,
on se fait un clin d'oeil,
on sait que ça a marché,
et on reviendra. On peut revenir.
D'où la nécessité
d'avoir un discours franc,
clair, précis, cash.
(musique rock)
-Pour les collectivités, le passage
du Tour de France est une aubaine.
La meilleure opération de
communication pour un territoire.
Mais accueillir une étape
a un prix :
70 000 euros pour un départ,
90 000 pour une arrivée.
Pourtant, chaque année,
plus de 250 villes
sont candidates,
y compris à l'étranger.
Même Tokyo souhaite accueillir
la Grande Boucle.
Christian Prudhomme dessine
chaque année le parcours.
Directeur du Tour depuis 2005,
cet ancien journaliste sportif
se frotte désormais aux politiques.
-Le Tour de France repose
sur trois piliers :
le pilier sportif, bien sûr,
mais aussi esthétique
et touristique,
magnifié par la télévision,
les images sont somptueuses !
Et on l'a sans doute vu,
plus encore qu'à l'ordinaire
avec le départ
de cette 100e édition,
où nous étions
pour la 1re fois en Corse.
Et puis, il y a le pilier social
du Tour de France.
Au bord des routes du Tour,
vous avez des familles,
des gens qui ont le sourire,
les anciens devant
les maisons de retraites,
les gamins devant
les centres aérés.
On y va en famille,
avec ses copains.
Y a des Français,
y a des étrangers,
toutes les catégories sociales.
C'est cet ensemble
qui fait le succès du Tour
qui est une épreuve à nulle
autre pareille, sans aucun doute.
("Rapper's Delight",
The Sugarhill Gang)
-Le Tour de France, c'est
le 3e événement sportif au monde,
après les Jeux Olympiques
et la Coupe du monde de football.
190 pays retransmettent
la Grande Boucle.
-On couvre donc
les cinq continents,
il est en haute définition
depuis 2007,
y a donc cinq motos au sol,
deux hélicos,
on a 11 caméras
sur le site d'arrivée
qui filment les derniers
kilomètres de la course
et quelques caméras
au niveau du protocole
pour les interviews, les ambiances,
et il arrive que nous ayons
quelques personnalités.
-A Marseille,
derrière la ligne d'arrivée,
des dizaines de cars-régie.
Des télévisions belges,
allemandes, néerlandaises,
australiennes ou américaines.
(il commente la course en anglais)
-Il va souffler un peu
à l'avant de la course...
-Pour cette 100e édition,
2000 journalistes sont accrédités.
-Il y a toute une partie
de notre public qui, je pense,
peut à peine citer
le vainqueur du jour,
mais qui est là pour regarder
ce spectacle
qu'est la France et ses paysages.
Y a une étude que j'avais vue
il y a quelques années,
qui disait que l'audience
au Danemark
- je reprends le Danemark -
était composée à 30 %
de femmes de plus de 50 ans
qui n'étaient là que pour ça
et qui étaient incapables,
parce que la question
était posée dans l'étude,
de citer le vainqueur du Tour
ou le porteur du maillot jaune.
C'était vraiment
pour se faire plaisir, s'asseoir,
passer un bon après-midi d'été,
regarder la France et ses paysages,
rendus merveilleusement
par la production
et France Télévisions.
-Va pas trop vers Marseille,
on a tout le temps.
Ils sont à 30 bornes de l'arrivée.
-Qui dit Tour de France
dit carte postale.
Chaque collectivité
fournit aux organisateurs
un descriptif précis
des monuments et paysages
que le spectateur
découvre sur son écran.
-On a un book de 300 pages
qui est distribué
aux commentateurs sur place ou a
l'étranger racontant site par site,
étape par étape
quelle en est l'histoire,
l'architecture, la région,
son nom, ses spécificités, etc.
Et c'est la bible.
Les commentateurs en sont fans
et eux-mêmes
apprennent plein de choses
et sont presque plus spécialistes
de la France que nous.
-On a le temps, Richard,
on a le temps.
Attention...
On va chercher
les calanques de Cassis.
Voilà, magnifique,
H2 à l'antenne
et toujours moto 2.
H2 et moto 2.
-Fin de l'étape.
Mark Cavendish
passe la ligne d'arrivée en tête.
219 km,
sous un soleil de plomb.
Et sur le podium,
c'est M. le sénateur-maire
qui salue les vainqueurs.
*-Vainqueur de cette étape !
-C'est la 35e fois
dans l'histoire du Tour
que le Tour s'arrête à Marseille.
Les retombées sont extraordinaires.
Vous le voyez,
y a une foule qui est réunie,
les gens sont heureux,
c'est la fête,
et pour une fois,
on parle en bien de Marseille
et pas du bashing auquel on est
habitué dans les médias parisiens.
-Le Tour, tout le monde y gagne.
C'est un partenariat subtil
entre élus et organisateurs.
-Si y a pas un élu qui nous dit oui
pour une ville départ
ou une ville arrivée,
on peut pas faire grand-chose.
D'autant que nous sommes sur 98,5 %
de routes départementales,
dépendantes des Conseils généraux.
Sans l'aval des élus,
on peut pas faire de parcours.
-Mission accomplie.
Demain, Aix-Montpellier.
(musique rock)
A Aix-en-Provence,
ce matin du 4 juillet,
c'est jour de départ.
Au village,
les terroirs sont à l'honneur.
Les partenaires du Tour aussi.
Ici, entre deux bouchées
de calissons,
la communication est reine.
Agnès Gougeat est une femme
pressée. Depuis 15 ans, elle gère
les délicats rapports
avec les politiques
et les collectivités
pour le Tour de France.
-Est-ce que tu peux,
pour la ville d'Aix
et la communauté du Pays d'Aix,
signer un panneau, s'il te plaît ?
Tiens, tiens, ils ont le leur.
-Je suis outillé !
-Je sais bien que t'es outillé !
-Où est-ce que je signe ?
-En haut, ils veulent.
-Ici ?
-Ca va aller ?
-Soigner les relations
avec les institutions
est la mission première d'Agnès,
alors ça vaut bien
une signature de Raymond Poulidor.
---
-Ah là là ! Vous les réchauffez ?
Vous faites quoi ?
Vous les mettez à l'ombre ?
-On les cuit.
-Ah ! Ah, génial !
C'est le bonbon préféré
de ma maman !
Donc, toutes les fêtes des mères
et tous ses anniversaires,
on était sûrs de manger
des calissons !
-Vous les avez dégustés ?
-Je viens d'en prendre un.
On se fait la liste ?
C'est dans 20 min.
On se fait la liste des élus.
-Tous les matins, il faut organiser
la cérémonie protocolaire
pour remercier les élus,
exercice de haute-voltige
qui nécessite un brin
de diplomatie quand les discordes
politiques s'invitent sur scène.
-Il est là, mais on le prend pas.
-Non.
-Je préfère te le dire...
-Oui.
-Il se peut qu'il monte de force.
-On pourra rien faire d'autre,
mais c'est pas vous
qui l'avez invité.
Y a un député qu'ils ont invité,
mais qui est pas
du même bord politique,
et donc, ils ont aucune envie
de l'avoir sur le podium.
Quand il va entendre
"la cérémonie protocolaire",
tu vas voir qu'il va...
-L'invité surprise :
Jean-David Ciot,
député PS des Bouches-du-Rhône.
C'est lui qui a battu
Maryse Joissains-Masini,
maire d'Aix, aux législatives.
-Bonjour, madame. Agnès Gougeat,
j'ai travaillé avec vos équipes
toute l'année,
merveilleusement, d'ailleurs...
-Ecoutez, c'est une réussite.
Vous avez insufflé
la belle rigueur,
et maintenant
qu'ils ont pris l'habitude,
ça va être une exigence pour moi.
-Ah bon ? A ce point-là ?
Dites-le fort
devant mon directeur !
(ils rient)
Le plus beau cadeau
qu'on puisse me faire,
c'est que les collectivités qui
travaillent ensemble sur le Tour
travaillent main
dans la main après.
Voilà, c'est l'objectif.
-On est dans l'excellence, là,
et l'excellence,
ça plaît à tout le monde.
-Tant mieux.
-Quel que soit votre statut,
tout le monde a besoin
d'excellence et de rigueur.
-Merci beaucoup,
chère madame.
-Moi qui ai suivi le Tour
toute mon adolescence,
je suis ravie.
-Clémence, tu viens ?
On a 50 personnes sur le podium.
-C'est l'heure de la cérémonie
protocolaire, et comme prévu,
le député est sur le podium,
mais les apparences sont sauves,
la photo de famille est belle
et lui aussi
aura droit à son cadeau.
L'objectif, à quelques mois
des municipales :
faire des élus des alliés du Tour,
et qu'importe le bord politique.
Le Tour est une énorme
galerie commerciale.
Certaines entreprises en profitent
pour faire du lobbying
auprès des élus. D'autres invitent
leurs clients à suivre la course.
L'organisation du Tour aussi
a ses invités.
Souvent des politiques.
-Y a des invités
qu'on retrouve sur place,
les VIP qu'on retrouve sur place,
et après, y a les "top VIP"
qui viennent en avion...
-C'est qui ?
-..directement du Bourget.
Ca peut être n'importe...
Enfin, "n'importe",
évidemment,
c'est pas n'importe qui.
Ca peut être les présidents
de nos partenaires,
ça peut être la ministre...
Mme la ministre des Sports
est venue dans l'avion du Tour.
En revanche,
le ministre des Transports
avait un déplacement
à faire en Corse,
il est venu par ses propres moyens
et il a fait l'étape,
puis a travaillé.
On a tous les cas de figure.
Nous avons les boutiques
officielles de produits du Tour...
-Depuis quelques années,
le métier d'Agnès a changé
et le mille-feuille institutionnel
y est pour beaucoup.
Avant, les conventions avec le Tour
étaient signées en majorité
par les villes.
Aujourd'hui, les interlocuteurs
se sont multipliés.
Régions, départements,
agglomérations :
la décentralisation
est passée par là.
-Ca peut faire beaucoup
de signataires.
Et on a des cas très particuliers.
Quelquefois, un Conseil général
va prendre en charge complètement
le ticket d'entrée pour une ville.
La ville va s'occuper
de tout l'aménagement technique,
la mise à disposition
des barrières,
elle va faire des frais
de communication, peut-être...
Mais le ticket d'entrée a été payé
par le Conseil général.
Du coup, ils vont vouloir avoir
la mainmise sur tout,
les accréditations,
les choses comme ça...
Il faut jongler
en permanence entre eux
et quelques fois, ils travaillent
ensemble pour le dossier,
mais ne se parlent pas.
On reçoit parfois des mails
où on nous dit :
"Je ne leur adresse plus
la parole.
"Il faut que ça passe par vous,
sinon..."
Donc, c'est dommage.
C'est d'autant plus dommage
que j'ai connu la période
où c'était complètement fédérateur.
-Tous les jours, Agnès fait l'étape
derrière la caravane.
-Arrête-toi pour dire bonjour
à Vincent. Attends !
Regarde qui est-ce
qu'il a comme invité.
T'as pas d'invité ?
-Agnès, ma chérie !
Je t'attendais !
Toujours la même copine ?
-La caravane,
c'est 180 véhicules, 37 marques
et 15 M d'objets distribués
sur le bord des routes.
Un événement attendu
des spectateurs.
47 % ne viennent que pour cela.
Mais pendant les 165 km de l'étape,
le téléphone continue de sonner.
Encore et toujours le protocole.
-Donc vous avez pas
à vous inquiéter de ça, d'accord ?
Pays de la Loire... Ah oui,
il vient à Fougères le 11, oui.
On l'invite au départ. C'est pas...
Oui, on est en Bretagne.
C'est que ça tout le temps.
-Aujourd'hui, Agnès fait une halte
au relais-étape.
Sur le parcours,
entre la ville départ et l'arrivée,
ce village éphémère est aussi dédié
aux partenaires du Tour.
Ici, les invités
peuvent regarder passer
la caravane, les coureurs
et photographier
des légendes vivantes.
Bernard Hinault, Bernard Thévenet,
Raymond Poulidor,
ces anciens coureurs
font partie de l'organisation.
Objectif : permettre aux clients,
aux élus, de tutoyer
ces mythes de leur enfance.
-C'est vous, ça ?
-Oui !
-Oh là là !
Qu'est-ce qu'elle est belle !
(on klaxonne au loin)
-J'ai toujours mis...
-Ah, très bien !
Monsieur est un vrai
collectionneur.
Il a des maillots
des anciens champions
et il refait le visage...
-Mon épouse.
-Bonjour, madame !
-Agnès Gougeat.
-Vous passez une bonne journée ?
Agnès Gougeat, je m'occupe des
relations avec les collectivités,
pour les villes départ et arrivée,
je suis désolée.
-On est trop petits, nous !
-Vous avez l'avantage
sans les embêtements.
-Agnès...
-Alors...
-Je voudrais vous remettre,
avant que vous partiez,
un diplôme que vous avez
bien mérité.
-Merci beaucoup.
-Elle est cachotière, Agnès !
-Mais je...
-Ah, si, si, si.
-Ca me touche beaucoup,
parce que...
..j'ai une vraie tendresse
pour les anciens coureurs
et en particulier
pour Charly Gaul et...
Quand Charly est décédé,
son épouse et sa fille m'ont dit :
"Mais t'inquiète pas, Agnès,
tu es toujours avec lui",
et elles ont mis ma photo
dans son cercueil.
Donc, voilà,
d'avoir ce tableau, ça me...
..ça me fait quelque chose.
Merci beaucoup.
-Merci, Agnès.
*-Petite femme,
mais grande par la classe.
Et je vais vous dire, elle fait
un travail d'enfer chez ASO.
-Il est là, l'autre champion.
-Patrick Hosotte.
-C'est vous, le champion ?
-Vous avez pas changé
par rapport aux vieux !
(ils rient)
-J'ai fait moins de Tours qu'eux !
-Je vais aller retrouver
mes interlocuteurs,
j'espère que j'en aurai,
parce qu'hier, à Marseille,
j'avais pas d'élus,
et pas d'interlocuteur
que j'avais eu toute l'année
pour trouver les élus
et Monsieur Gaudin rentrait
de Paris
et on était pas sûrs
que son avion serait à l'heure,
c'était un peu ennuyeux,
mais tout s'est arrangé.
*-Grenadine, menthe...
-Banderoles, panneaux,
barrières, sur le parcours,
rien n'est laissé au hasard.
Chaque détail est filmé
pour faciliter
le travail des collectivités
l'année suivante.
-Allez, un petit podium
protocolaire, un de plus...
(musique légère)
-Fin de l'étape
entre Aix et Montpellier.
Les coureurs arrivent.
Les élus seront bientôt
sur le podium.
-Bonjour.
-M. Touchon.
-Agnès Gougeat, en charge des
relations avec les collectivités.
-Très bien.
-J'aurai le plaisir
de vous accueillir.
-Pr Touchon, adjoint au maire.
-Enchantée.
-Maires,
présidents d'agglomération,
de Conseil régional,
tous doivent garder
un souvenir inoubliable
de ce moment partagé
avec les cyclistes.
-M. le président...
-Ca va ?
-Très bien !
Je vous invite à monter
sur le podium,
je vais chercher Hélène Mandroux.
Hélène, alors, cette étape ?
-Super !
-C'était bien, oui ?
-M. le président Bourquin,
je peux vous inviter à vous
installer... Il faut vous serrer.
Voilà...
-Sur ce podium, Hélène Mandroux,
maire de Montpellier,
pose avec son rival,
Jean-Pierre Moure,
président de l'agglomération.
Un cliché rare.
*-Mme Mandroux,
M. Moure, M. Bourquin,
M. Martin et le Pr. Touchon.
Hélène Mandroux, bien sûr,
maire de Montpellier.
Jean-Pierre Moure,
président...
-Et une journée réussie
pour Agnès
qui aura réuni les nombreux
représentants des collectivités
sur une même scène.
*(discours au micro)
(musique rap)
Souvent, à l'issue de l'étape,
les élus offrent un cocktail
aux représentants du Tour.
Une manière d'oublier le protocole
et de nourrir des liens
souvent amicaux
entre les organisateurs
et les élus.
Hélène Mandroux, maire socialiste,
n'est pas présente
à cette cérémonie organisée
par Jean-Pierre Moure.
Une réception se tiendra
à la mairie dans quelques heures.
Mais tout cela n'aurait rien à voir
avec la course aux municipales.
-La mairie est invitée.
On a des calendriers
les uns et les autres à respecter.
Y a pas de problème
par rapport à ça.
Nous fonctionnons très bien avec
les représentants de la mairie.
J'étais avec Mme Mandroux,
pas de problème.
La compétition électorale
est un exercice de la démocratie,
c'est salutaire.
Non, y a aucun problème
par rapport à ces questions-là.
Dans un an, c'est un Tour de France
spécial pour les collectivités !
On est habitués
à ces matchs également.
*-Salut, Montpellier !
-Ce matin, on part
de la place de la Comédie
à Montpellier.
Le Tour, c'est 12 M de spectateurs
sur le bord des routes.
(musique rap)
Un des derniers grands spectacles
sportifs populaires
et gratuits.
Les cyclistes sont encore
accessibles, disponibles,
près du public.
-Allez, courage à toi.
-Dans la course,
22 équipes, 198 coureurs
et 34 nationalités.
Depuis 1962,
les équipes
ne sont plus nationales,
mais sponsorisées
par des entreprises.
Un investissement
qui rapporte aux sponsors,
mais surtout
à Amaury Sport Organisation.
En 2011, ASO aurait engrangé
un bénéfice net
de 32,5 M d'euros,
en grande partie
grâce au Tour.
Comme chaque matin,
le cortège accueille quelques
invités de marque sur l'étape.
Aujourd'hui, Bernard Thibault.
-La CGT est présente
traditionnellement
et historiquement
sur le Tour de France
en tant que militante
et aussi en tant que partenaire.
Vous savez, le Tour de France
doit aussi sa renommée,
notamment, au fait
qu'il y a concomitance
entre le calendrier du Tour
et les congés payés,
une grande conquête sociale.
De ce point de vue-là,
je me félicite
que les organisateurs
ouvrent des fenêtres
permettant de relater
ce qui se passe
dans telle ou telle contrée,
y compris sur le plan social,
et en ce moment,
il y a beaucoup à dire.
-Tous les syndicats
sont représentés dans la caravane.
Un partenariat plus que stratégique
pour les organisateurs.
La meilleure façon d'éviter
les manifestations syndicales
sur le Tour.
On ne bloque pas le Tour de France.
(la foule acclame les coureurs)
Et comme à l'accoutumée,
Mme le maire donne le départ.
---
-C'est un grand moment d'émotion.
Surtout, ce qui pour moi
est important,
c'est de voir le bonheur,
non seulement des Montpelliérains,
mais aussi de tous les Français
et des touristes étrangers.
J'ai donné 100 000 euros
et je crois que les retombées,
c'est 8, 9, 10 fois plus !
C'est incroyable.
Tout à l'heure,
Christian Prudhomme me disait
que sur l'ensemble
du Tour de France,
c'est plusieurs millions
de personnes qui regardent le Tour.
C'est exceptionnel.
-A Bagnères-de-Bigorre,
dans les Hautes-Pyrénées,
on attend la première étape
de montagne.
Ici, la Grande Boucle
passe depuis 1910.
Tourmalet, Aspin, Peyresourde,
ces cols mythiques
ont écrit l'histoire du Tour.
Alors, entre les Pyrénées
et la petite reine,
c'est un tandem presque amoureux.
La pratique du vélo
est en pleine ascension.
22 M de Français
sont adeptes de la bicyclette.
Depuis des années,
les Hautes-Pyrénées
misent sur le cyclotourisme
pour dynamiser l'économie.
Ce samedi matin,
sur la place du village,
quelques cyclistes sont attablés.
Belges, Irlandais, Néerlandais,
ils ont franchi
plusieurs cols ce matin-là.
-On termine ici après avoir fait
650 km de cols et de vallées
en une semaine.
On a une douzaine de cols,
les plus mythiques,
mais aussi les cols de Beyrède
et de Couret,
ce que les coureurs
ne feront jamais.
D'abord parce que la caravane
ne saurait pas y passer,
et ça va chercher dans les 10, 12,
14 et un maximum de 18 %.
(anglais)
Vous ne restez pas ici ?
-Nous ne restons que 3-4 jours.
-Ca, c'est Baronnies,
ce côté, c'est vraiment très joli.
(piano doux)
-Un mois avant, le Tourmalet
était sous 7 m de neige.
---
Plus bas, des dizaines de coureurs
se préparent à la montée du géant.
Un événement qui signe le début
de la saison touristique
dans les Hautes-Pyrénées.
Il est 8h du matin et toute
la famille du cyclisme est réunie
pour honorer ce col légendaire,
le plus emprunté
de l'histoire du Tour.
A 75 ans, un des doyens
affiche encore 15 000 km
de route par an.
-J'ai monté 40-50 fois
le Tourmalet.
J'allais en vacances
à Luz-Saint-Sauveur
et donc, le Tourmalet,
c'était ma...
Soit je partais sur La Mongie
et je revenais par Lourdes
et je faisais mon circuit
comme ça, ou à l'envers.
Ca, c'est bien
parce que c'est convivial.
C'est formidable, ça,
moi, j'adore.
-Quelques courageux sont en costume
et vélo d'époque,
car cette année,
on fête aussi le centenaire
de l'aventure d'Eugène Christophe,
célèbre coureur du Tour.
Et ce matin-là,
Jean-Marie Leblanc, ancien
directeur du Tour, donne le départ.
-Cinq, quatre, trois...
..deux, un...
(détonation)
("Come Out And Play",
The Offspring)
---
-C'est une star internationale.
On s'en aperçoit d'autant mieux
lorsqu'on crée des événements
qui amènent des cyclistes
de toute la France
et de l'étranger.
Aujourd'hui, certains sont venus
du fin fond de l'Espagne,
on a des Australiens,
un Américain, par exemple,
et ce Tourmalet
a un pouvoir d'attraction
extraordinaire
et c'est une façon,
encore une fois,
de nous rappeler
ce que représente ce fameux col.
Nous qui l'avons chez nous
et qui pourrions avoir un regard
un peu détaché, au contraire,
grâce à cet événement
de la montée du géant du Tourmalet
et a fortiori le Tour de France,
ça nous rappelle
qu'on a ici un col d'un prestige
qui dépasse nos frontières.
Le cyclotourisme est un gisement
économique en expansion
qui est très loin
d'avoir atteint sa maturité.
Des nouvelles nations émergent,
les nations de l'hémisphère sud,
notamment.
Australiens, Néo-Zélandais,
Sud-Africains, désormais,
affluent de plus en plus
vers les Pyrénées,
et notamment les Hautes-Pyrénées,
avec ce col du Tourmalet
qui a un pouvoir d'attraction
qu'on a peine à imaginer.
C'est un peu la quête du Graal.
-Le Tour s'est construit sur
ces mythes des forçats de la route,
des légendes qui dépassent
les frontières françaises
et sont un levier pour l'économie
locale. Le tourisme
est la 1re activité économique
des Hautes-Pyrénées.
Cela représente des milliers
d'emplois et 1 Mrd d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires.
Une manne indispensable
pour ce département
de 230 000 habitants
niché au creux des cols.
-On a fait coïncider la montée
du géant avec le centenaire
Eugène Christophe.
Ce centenaire coïncide
avec la 100e édition du Tour.
C'est une conjonction formidable
pour nous, promotionnellement.
-Eugène Christophe est une grande
figure du Tour de France.
Ce coureur cassa la fourche
de son vélo dans la descente
du Tourmalet, en 1913,
et la répara lui-même
à la forge de Ste-Marie-de-Campan.
Alors leader,
il perd la course,
mais construit sa légende.
Le département a donc imaginé
une reconstitution grandeur nature
de cette saga. Objectif :
communiquer.
Ce jour-là, Christian Prudhomme,
directeur du Tour,
est présent aux côtés des élus.
Un moment convivial
qui scelle les relations
entre politiques et responsables
de la course.
Des rapports qui pèsent lourd
dans le tracé du parcours,
et chaque année,
il passe dans les Hautes-Pyrénées.
Un mois plus tard,
le 6 juillet 2013,
la veille de l'étape
Saint-Girons - Bagnères-de-Bigorre.
Accueillir le Tour,
c'est aussi assurer sa sécurité.
Ici, en zone rurale,
c'est la mission des gendarmes,
et cette année, un invité de marque
est attendu sur l'étape pyrénéenne.
-Il est officiel que le président
de la République sera sur l'étape
du Tour de France dimanche.
Ca suppose un dispositif
qui vient se greffer
sur le dispositif initial
du Tour de France
afin de sécuriser
les déplacements du président.
-Il faut reconnaître le parcours
du cortège présidentiel,
rien n'est laissé au hasard.
-On met les postes qu'on a dit.
Le seul problème...
-Sauf celui-là, on le décale ici.
-Voilà, faut le décaler ici.
-Oui.
-On le décale ici, et là,
on met personne ?
-On demande à une équipe
de motards de tourner...
-Y aura une voiture de route.
-Ca y est, on a fini.
On a fait les allées Maintenon,
le Salut, qui sera peut-être
pas pris, mais on a reconnu ça,
les thermes
avec le sens interdit...
J'ai deux gars qui seraient prêts,
et sinon, on le fait là.
-C'est par rapport à son programme
qu'on vérifie l'itinéraire
qu'il empruntera
et qu'on prévoit la sécurisation
pour que le cortège progresse
dans de bonnes conditions.
-Divers itinéraires sont prévus.
L'escorte ne doit jamais
être immobilisée.
Sur les hauteurs de Bagnères,
les gendarmes ont aménagé une aire
d'atterrissage
pour l'hélicoptère du président.
-Malgré tout ce qui peut
être prévu,
on est jamais à l'abri
d'un changement de situation
ou d'un problème particulier qui
fait qu'on doit trouver un plan B.
Donc, dès que c'est prévu,
on a aucune difficulté
à orienter le dispositif
sur l'une ou l'autre des versions.
-En moyenne,
24 000 policiers et gendarmes
sécurisent le parcours du Tour,
et chaque jour,
la route est privatisée 3h
par arrêté préfectoral
pour laisser passer la course.
Un partenariat qui a un coût :
2 M d'euros reversés chaque année
par ASO au ministère de l'Intérieur
pour la mise à disposition
de ses équipes.
-Vous restez pas sur la route.
-Non, non.
On vous laisse passer
pour partir dans l'autre sens.
-Parce que plus haut, vous aurez
plus de place non plus...
-L''autre mission
des forces de l'ordre :
gérer l'afflux des spectateurs
dans les cols.
Cette année,
une seule étape
traverse les Pyrénées.
Alors les camping-caristes
se sont installés très tôt.
-Il vaut mieux garder
des places pour demain,
pour laisser monter
en cas d'afflux.
Si tout est calme, on laisse
remonter les gens sur le matin.
Y aura l'afflux des gens
qui quittent l'étape précédente
et qui vont arriver.
Ils vont nous mettre le bazar
avant la nuit.
On se le gère comme ça,
et demain matin,
quand c'est un peu plus calme,
on laisse remonter.
-Mission délicate
pour le commandant. Six cars de CRS
doivent stationner
au col de la Hourquette d'Ancizan
pour assurer la sécurité
du président.
Problème : il faut déplacer
des camping-cars
installés depuis
déjà plusieurs jours.
-S'ils veulent pas partir,
on leur dira qu'il y aura
un arrêté préfectoral
qui les contraindra
à bouger dans la nuit,
que personne a rien à y gagner,
qu'on aura juste perdu du temps.
Pour le bien de tout le monde,
on va essayer de faire
pour le mieux.
-Protéger les coureurs
et les personnalités,
une tâche difficile.
On compte parfois
des centaines de milliers
de spectateurs en montagne.
-Messieurs, bonjour !
Nous venons vous annoncer...
-On vient vous embêter.
-..une mauvaise nouvelle.
Non, je vous explique.
Il va falloir vous resserrer...
-Vous resserrer entre vous.
-..pour laisser plus de place.
-Vous allez gagner même pas 1,5 m
et là, 50 cm !
-Nous, on est là pour s'organiser.
-Pour ne pas avoir à vous déloger,
aidez-nous,
resserrez-vous au maximum...
-Oui, on va se resserrer.
-..et tout ira bien.
-Le Tour, c'est vraiment magique.
C'est une ambiance
qu'on retrouve pas
dans les autres sports.
C'est quelque chose de magique,
surtout quand
on est camping-cariste.
Un Tour de France,
s'il avait pas de camping-cars,
ce serait pas un Tour de France !
-Ici, le camping sauvage est
interdit, mais quand le Tour passe,
la loi est quelque peu
mise entre parenthèses.
-Le Tour de France,
c'est aussi le public
qui le fait vivre,
et c'est dans les cols mythiques
que le gens profitent du paysage,
et qu'on peut voir au mieux
l'effort des coureurs.
Donc, je pense que
sans les spectateurs,
le Tour de France perdrait
un peu de sa notoriété.
Il faut bien laisser
aux gens l'opportunité
de venir la veille
pour se positionner,
et puis c'est une petite parenthèse
qu'on offre à tout le monde
qui permet de rendre tout ça
un peu piquant.
-Jour J.
Le Tour part de Saint-Girons
en Ariège,
direction Bagnères-de-Bigorre,
Hautes-Pyrénées.
-On colle pas trop parce qu'on
arrive sur le giratoire,
le rond-point, au PK 57.
Je vais vous dire ce qu'il faut
mettre, je vais approcher un peu.
-Au petit matin, avant l'étape,
ce sont les équipes
des départements
qui préparent la route.
-Nous, le rôle de l'équipe,
ce qu'on appelle
la "patrouille avant",
c'est de signaler
tous les points dangereux,
surtout pour la caravane,
plus que les coureurs.
Eux, avec les oreillettes,
sont au courant de ce qui se passe.
Mais la caravane, elle,
circule en double voie.
Donc, ils ont besoin de savoir
sur les giratoires
s'ils peuvent partir
des deux côtés
la sortie,
si elle est à droite ou à gauche,
les rétrécissements, pour qu'ils
se remettent sur une file
et les dos-d'âne. C'est une superbe
expérience humaine, déjà,
parce qu'on voit des collègues
d'autres départements,
voir comment ils fonctionnent,
et c'est une chaîne humaine
incroyable.
On voit des gens
de différents milieux,
et puis moi qui adore le sport,
je suis gâté !
-Sécurisation des routes,
entretien des chaussées, balisage,
si une équipe de neuf agents
permanents suit l'intégralité
du Tour,
pas moins de 3000 fonctionnaires
départementaux sont mobilisés.
(musique flamenco)
Au même moment, à Saint-Girons,
au village départ :
réunion au pavillon de l'Assemblée
des départements de France.
-La descente ?
-La descente du Portet-d'Aspet...
-C'est sinueux ?
-C'est quand même très pentu.
-Oui...
C'est un point général
sur l'étape,
sa préparation, et sur ce qui
va se passer pendant la journée.
L'objectif est de faire
un tour de table
avec les représentants du Tour,
les représentants locaux
des départements concernés,
nos équipes
pour vérifier l'état de la route,
savoir si des dernières retouches
sont nécessaires. Ensuite,
chacun prend la route
à son échelon, on reste en contact
et on corrige les éventuels
éléments vus le matin.
-Cette année, 37 départements
sont traversés
par la Grande Boucle
et c'est l'Assemblée
des départements de France
qui coordonne leur action.
-Nous, en tant qu'ADF,
les contacts quotidiens
qu'on a avec les départements,
nous permettent de redescendre
et remonter de l'information.
C'est un noeud stratégique,
une passerelle entre le Tour
et les départements.
(musique dynamique)
-4h avant la course, deux agents
départementaux ouvrent la route.
Ils vérifient les installations
des équipes du matin
et l'état du parcours
avant le passage de la caravane.
---
-Si y a un coup de vent
et si la rubalise se casse,
ça peut venir sur la chaussée
et se prendre dans les rayons
des cyclistes.
C'est assez dangereux.
(musique funk)
---
-La patrouille technique
a repéré au PK 29,
ça doit être du liquide
de refroidissement sur la route.
Contrôlez vos véhicules,
y a un véhicule qui perd
du liquide de refroidissement.
-Objectif des services de voirie :
un parcours parfait
pour éviter l'accident.
-Vous pourriez m'attacher la botte
de paille, qu'elle bascule pas ?
Et l'autre également,
au niveau de la sortie.
Soit du fil de fer, soit...
-On en a.
-Sur les cols,
on a pas mal de courses cyclistes
pendant toute la période
du printemps et de l'été,
donc, on s'acharne à maintenir
quand même des routes
en état de sécurité correct
pour les cyclistes.
-Bonjour, messieurs-dames.
-Bonjour.
(musique funk)
-Après le passage de la caravane,
les équipes nettoient la route.
Sur les 3500 km de course,
la quasi-totalité
des chaussées empruntées
sont des départementales.
Alors, une fois le parcours
du Tour rendu public,
les services de voiries se lancent,
quand cela est nécessaire,
dans la réfection des routes.
Tarif pour
Amaury Sport Organisation :
250 000 euros.
-Le choix de l'itinéraire
et de son état
est de la responsabilité
de l'organisateur de la course,
donc d'ASO,
en revanche, nous, derrière,
au titre du partenariat
qu'on a signé,
entre l'Assemblée des départements
de France et le Tour,
nous avons des tâches à accomplir.
Ces tâches, c'est proposer
un itinéraire soigné
sur lequel on est intervenus
pour le préparer,
sur lequel on intervient
pour du balisage,
de la signalisation,
mais, on n'a pas
une obligation de résultat.
Ce que demande le Tour,
c'est essentiellement
ce travail de mise en place,
de préparation,
de mise à disposition
de moyens matériels, humains,
et puis après,
eux gèrent la course.
(musique à suspense)
-Les coureurs viennent
de quitter Saint-Girons,
direction Bagnères-de-Bigorre :
168 km,
cinq cols,
donc quatre de première catégorie.
Devant la course, c'est "Gros Léon"
qui ouvre la route.
Sa mission : préparer le parcours
avant le passage des cyclistes.
---
-Gros Léon a pour mission
de travailler
juste devant la course.
Suite à la caravane,
y a beaucoup de déchets
sur la route.
Donc, du gravier est remis
par la caravane,
parce qu'ils roulent en quinconce,
eux, dans les petites routes.
Ils roulent sur les accotements,
nous ramènent du gravier.
On arrose les plaques de ressuage,
ces plaques de goudron noires
qui collent quand il fait chaud et
sont dangereuses pour les coureurs.
On les refroidit.
On emmène 2000 litres d'eau, nous,
et on emmène des bottes de paille
pour sécuriser les endroits
qui ont été oubliés.
Voilà, c'est la principale mission
de Gros Léon.
-Je suis, moi, au PK 113.9.
Ressuage sur l'extérieur,
donc, on va faire passer
un peu de flotte dessus,
sur une épingle.
(musique pop-rock)
-Le fluorescent Gros Léon
est un camion prêté
par le département des Vosges.
Le seul en France.
Une jolie
opération de communication
tout au long du tracé
pour ce territoire
très peu visité par le Tour.
---
(musique festive)
Au même moment,
la caravane publicitaire
traverse Bagnères-de-Luchon,
en Haute-Garonne.
Dispositif musclé
des forces de l'ordre :
François Hollande est arrivé.
-Vous avez déjà la casquette jaune.
-M. Hollande, félicitation.
-Le président
à Bagnères-de-Luchon :
pour le Tour de France, plus qu'un
symbole pour cette ville sinistrée
quelques semaines auparavant
par des crues historiques.
Ici, certaines routes
empruntées par le Tour
se sont révélées impraticables
et des dizaines de villages
se sont retrouvés coupés du monde.
-La passerelle
que nous allons traverser,
telle qu'elle était
le jour de la crue.
Là, on était sur une rue
qui s'était transformée
en véritable torrent de boue.
-Oui, charriant...
-Des quantités de bois,
des matériaux, qui ont rempli
le lit de la rivière.
C'est un autre sujet pour...
-Un autre travail de les enlever.
-Les services de voierie
ont travaillé d'arrache-pied
pour accueillir la course
et montrer une station thermale
capable d'accueillir les touristes
en ce début juillet.
-Les images du Tour de France,
largement diffusées,
sont très bonnes.
-Oui, elles contribuent à montrer
que vous avez tout fait,
dans un délai record, d'ailleurs,
pour remettre en état
et accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions les touristes.
-Nous sommes commerçants
et nous espérons
que le touriste viendra en masse
parce qu'il y a eu une publicité
comme quoi nous étions
très sinistrés
et que la montagne
n'était pas accessible.
Si, y a des sites ouverts,
il faut absolument
qu'on retrouve notre tourisme.
-Bonjour.
-Tous les présidents
de la République
s'invitent sur les bords du Tour.
(musique douce)
François Hollande vivra la fin
de l'étape pyrénéenne
dans la voiture
de Christian Prudhomme,
directeur de la course.
---
Les coureurs entrent
dans les Hautes-Pyrénées.
Avant Bagnères-de-Bigorre,
ils devront avaler trois cols
à plus de 7 % de dénivelé.
L'Irlandais Daniel Martin
passe la ligne d'arrivée
avec plus de 30 min d'avance
sur l'horaire prévu.
Christopher Froome reste en jaune
et c'est le président
de la République
qui félicite
les vainqueurs du jour.
(sifflet)
---
Après la course,
c'est le départ des caravanes
et le début du nettoyage.
Et une fois de plus,
c'est la mission
des services de voierie.
La Grande Boucle est souvent
épinglée car peu écologique.
12 M de spectateurs,
2400 véhicules, 3500 km,
et de nombreux cadeaux trop souvent
abandonnés sur le bord de la route.
Bilan : une empreinte carbone
astronomique.
(musique lounge)
-On a eu le passage
sur le col de la Hourquette,
qui était le dernier col
des Pyrénées, pour ainsi dire,
et donc, on a eu une affluence
du public assez conséquente,
notamment en camping-cars qui
sont là depuis plus d'une semaine.
Donc, bien sûr, ça a généré
un certain nombre de déchets
et on met à disposition
des containers, des sacs poubelles,
et puis maintenant,
il faut tout collecter
et nettoyer
tous les abords des routes
qui ont pu être
un peu souillées.
-Chaque étape du Tour génère
entre 10 et 20 tonnes de déchets,
mais pour une arrivée en montagne,
on culmine parfois à 50 tonnes.
Depuis quelques années,
les organisateurs du Tour
cherchent à réduire
cette pollution.
(musique RnB)
-Ca a nettement évolué.
On a essayé de sensibiliser
un petit peu
les différents publicitaires,
déjà, pour qu'ils donnent
moins d'objets promotionnels,
on va dire,
envahissants ou encombrants
et peut-être plus utiles.
Maintenant, ils donnent beaucoup
de porte-clés, de stylos
ou de petits objets utiles
à la vie courante,
et les gens ont plus tendance
à les garder
et à moins les jeter.
Y a l'avant Tour,
le pendant et l'après.
L'avant-Tour,
c'est presque le plus gros.
Parce qu'on a déjà fait
plusieurs rotations
avec des déchets...
On essaye d'avoir toujours
les sacs le plus vide possible
pour éviter que les gens jettent,
bien sûr.
-Le Tour traverse régulièrement
des sites classés Natura 2000,
des espaces naturels très fragiles.
L'émergence
des questions
de développement durable
a modifié les comportements
des spectateurs.
-Ils ont mis beaucoup dans les
sacs poubelle ou y a du sauvage ?
-Non, pas de sauvage,
par contre, le plateau, là,
t'en as un peu partout
dans la nature, des sacs.
-Ils en ont mis en sauvage ?
-Ils ont fait des tas partout.
-Ils ont laissé des paquets.
-Ouais.
-D'accord.
On s'aperçoit
que ça va beaucoup mieux.
Les gens, je pense qu'ils ont
aussi la mentalité.
Quand ils arrivent dans la montagne
et voient que c'est propre,
que c'est quand même
très, très beau, le paysage,
ils se disent quand même :
"On va pas laisser ça là".
Ils ramassent.
-On avait mis pas mal de sacs
et c'est un tas assez propre.
-Ah ouais, ouais...
-C'est tout ramassé.
-Ils ont pas foutu trop en vrac ?
-Non, ça va.
-Ils ont bien regroupé ?
-Oui.
-Plus tard dans la soirée,
les organisateurs
retrouvent les élus locaux
autour d'un buffet.
Ici aussi,
les inondations
ont provoqué des dégâts.
Les coureurs ont légué
leur prime d'étape et le Tour
a fait un don de 30 000 euros
aux départements sinistrés :
Hautes-Pyrénées et Haute-Garonne.
Entre 2 bouchées,
le futur parcours
est sur toutes les lèvres.
-Je ne vous dévoilerai pas
le parcours du Tour 2014
puisque ce sera
le 23 octobre prochain,
et vous êtes les bienvenus
au Palais des Congrès,
mais oui, Michel, oui, François,
bien sûr que nous passerons
par le Tourmalet l'an prochain.
Vous m'avez expliqué que la route
était complètement zébrée,
coupée en 10 endroits,
qu'elle était arrachée,
le Tourmalet est le 1er géant
du Tour de France,
et nous viendrons, bien sûr,
l'année prochaine,
pour l'honorer à nouveau.
-On est dans l'ordre du symbole,
mais c'est aussi, me semble-t-il,
au-delà du symbole,
le fait qu'ASO, et en particulier
Christian Prudhomme,
directeur du cyclisme,
a très bien mesuré quelle était
l'importance du traumatisme
et comment, à leur niveau,
ils peuvent nous aider
à surmonter ce traumatisme.
-En 2014, les coureurs
vont donc gravir une nouvelle fois
le Tourmalet. Plus qu'un symbole,
un gage de renaissance
pour ce territoire lourdement
touché, car le Tour de France
n'est pas qu'une simple épreuve
au creux de juillet,
mais une course
à l'écoute des régions
et des terroirs.
Et malgré les scandales,
le dopage, les attaques,
le mythe perdure
et la compétition continue.
Et c'est bien une des plus belles
cartes de visite
pour la France et ses territoires.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA FRANCE
(générique)
---